So the best answer is the second choice. The
first rule by itself is not sufficient. And the
reason the first rule doesn't work is that there's
no base case. We can keep producing parents of
ancestor and parent of parent of parent of ancestor.
But we can never stop because there's no rule
that defines ancestor in terms of something other than
itself. The second rule is a recursive definition that works;
it says our parent is our ancestor. And the parent
of an ancestor is also an ancestor. And so, this
will give us exactly the set of ancestors that we
showed before, that it will be the parent, the parent of
the parent, the parent of the parent of the parent,
the parents of the parents of the parents of the
parents and so forth, covering all of our ancestors. The
third choice will also produce that same set, but it has
an unnecessary rule that we only need these
two rules. Here we've said, parent, parent of parent,
parent of parent of ancestor. We can still
combine these rules to produce any word that is
parent of parent of parent of any number
of times ending in parent, but it's less elegant
than the second answer, which only needs two
rules to produce exactly the same set of ancestors.